morning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised so as we connected
the dots for him prophetically you know
from Revelation 13 and other places in
the Bible he just was like yes he was
like this is the problem he actually
pulled out his phone he said you want to
know the real problem behind this this
this uh conflict and we're like yeah
sure so he pulls the phone and he
Scrolls down there's that art
installation at the Vatican supposed to
I think represent the second coming of
Jesus but it's like super demonic yeah
right so he pulls and the pope sitting
in front of his art installation and he
just shows us on his phone he says this
is the real problem he's like this is
actually what's behind all of the
conflict that's happening right now so
he's recognizing that they're demons you
know what I mean it's like wow like like
this guy like he understands more than
we we recognize that that that that that
that grab for political and religious
power that is soon to break upon the
whole world is actually what's
motivating much of the conflict that we
see and it's like this is context this
is why the Bible is so important to give
people
handle on what's
Happening welcome back to LED live today
we're going to get an update from Brock
Meyer my brother in Gideon rescue
welcome to the show Brock thank you
thank you he has so many interesting and
crazy stories from being on the front
lines of War if you've ever wondered
what war is like it's awful and uh just
uh looking forward to this conversation
because this is a hard thing to to
engage in and witness and it just
doesn't make sense in in the bigger
picture so I want to hear from you your
thoughts on on uh you know how do we
make sense of this and um you know is
there any good that comes out of
this yeah it's it's you know I think the
only way we can really understand the
context for where we're at is biblically
yeah you know so like when Jesus says at
the end of time you'd see wars and
rumors of wars it's a very specific
point of reference that he's given to
humanity to say this is the state of
what the world's going to be like and he
said those are the beginnings yeah of
Sorrows that's the beginning and so
what's interesting is that actually I
think I saw a statistic that in 30 years
like so three decades we've never been
closer to like World conflict than we
are right now like 100 160 some OD
conflicts worldwide right now as we
speak
2024 so the world is on the brink of
like tearing itself AP yeah yeah and you
think about how many countries are there
right right not more than 300 and what
are they fighting for if you actually
like look at a map we were looking at a
map last night and I mean there's these
little tiny countries look at how big
rushes it's this massive piece of land
and it's dis it's having a discrepancy
over a little piece of dirt over here
wow you know and you just go wow like
man you got all this land you you don't
want somebody else to kind of have have
their peace too you know greed the love
of money is the root of all evil the
evil of murder and all these things the
root of it is greed I want more yeah
what what what I think makes sad me sad
and um maybe we can get into a little
bit of this Brock is is is just hearing
stories of the hatred that these people
have for another people group what
people are we talking about where is the
war happening right now I'm ignorant
with this stuff so the two conflicts
that we've been involved with have been
in Israel and also Ukraine so Israel and
Hamas and Russia and Ukraine but you
bring up an interesting point you know
hatred is is something that needs to
feed off of hatred you know like
violence has to feed off of violence
it's really difficult to to to hate
someone that doesn't return hatred right
to to be violent towards someone that
doesn't return violence this why the
gospel is so incredible and Jesus says
like turn the other cheek or like go the
extra mile like I mean the Romans were
like hated nobody like the Romans and
yet he's giving advice saying like hey
if they compel you go with them
counterintuitive don't return evil with
evil but return evil with good it's like
dumping hot ashes on their head what was
the story was it Elijah or Elisha that
took the whole Army blind it was Elisha
it was Elisha what amazing can you
imagine the video of that if a bunch of
Russians were like dude we made you guys
some donuts you want some donuts like
what would these people
do it would completely revolutionize and
change they didn't come back to Israel
for a long time probably not even that
generation right anybody who was there
that day was like we're not going back
cuz those guys fed us a feast you know
like they were our friends they could
have killed us and they didn't I I
wonder if there was people like don't
eat it it's probably poisoned don't eat
it you know well well the King right the
Israelite King he's like he's like my
Lord Elisha like what do I do now like
can we kill him you know like he's he's
like he's ready he's ready he's ready to
out you know life is like hold on man
like you don't understand the gift that
God's giving you right now right talk
about flexing your power dude if you
were like we just made you a meal wow
yeah you know it is that's beautiful
it's power on a whole another level and
and that's a sad reality is you know
when we're when we're in Israel you know
I I didn't grow up in the 60s you know
here in the United States or the 50s
where racial divides were a very real
thing you know in the United States um
and I know we have challenges even today
but but honestly I don't think we
understand anything about racism right
hat for generations and and we saw that
in Israel it's amazing like in Israel
there is I mean there's entire
communities that are Muslim communities
like no Jew is allowed in these
communties they they have a giant sign
it's in red white letters and it says if
you're a if you're a Jew and you're
found in our community you're not coming
out alive that's basically what is this
a racial Jew or a religious Jew or is
there does it matter it doesn't matter
like racial religious Jew if you're a
Jew like you're not coming out alive
from this community right and and it's
so sad because distinctly we had this
kid in the back who was a Jewish kid you
know we were driving back from church
and he's the pastor's son you know he's
like I'm not going in there guys and and
we just asked him why can't we go in
this he's like he's like I I won't make
it out alive you know he's like 10 years
older he like my son's age and and so as
we were driving to his settlement which
was the exit to the left and the and
this was right in Bethany the ancient
town of Lazarus right so this Laz
lazarus's town is now Muslim Community
and we were in Maul which is like right
to the left which is a Jewish settlement
and so I accidentally like got in the
wrong exit Lane and I was going into the
Muslim Community I remember thinking oh
my goodness like I've got I've got this
kid in the back and he's a Jew like I
got to figure out how to turn this car
around you know wow I me it was it was
palpable like the fear was even though
nothing happened we were able to turn
around get out of there no big deal but
still
it's so sad to see that kind of hatred
in a modern day right like like the
world talks so much about love and
acceptance and it's like even though
that's a false conversation like they
they haven't even tackled the reality
that in this world today there's very
real hatred that how do we how do you
solve that you know and the only way you
can solve it is with you know an actual
intelligent conversation and
demonstration to someone that hey we're
actually the same you know maybe
different skin color different culture
or whatever but at the basis we're all
human
beings made in God's image I I I think
we've completely begun to Lo lose that
perspective in in you know many many
stories about the war and I remember
having some conversations with you about
just you know this this this whole drone
Warfare how evil this is and
disconnected um you
know war war is awful to begin with and
I don't know if people feel better
because you're not looking the guy
straight eye and eye you know it that I
I believe that these video games and not
maybe not the Creator came up with it
but I believe Satan is using this as a
desensitization tool people are playing
video games and they're murdering
virtually murdering people in a
simulator hundreds of people all day
long and the military is using those
games as a recruitment tool so they're
like dude you're at the top in the world
you want to you want to do it for real
and the kid's like no I'm not into war
no dude you use a mouse and you're on a
screen and you just blow people away
like you do on the game so do they have
video games in in Israel and I mean are
these do these kids talk about the the
problem of video games there I'm sure
video games is universal problem but it
it really gets to the heart of yeah
worldwide worldwide yeah I you know I
think the uh challenge is that um it's a
mindset that is just you know you're
surrounded by this mindset that you know
every Palestinian Young young person
that grows up is going to be a Hamas
terrorist and that's what they believe
you know so to them to wipe them out now
makes more sense right before they they
grow up and they actually become that
terrorist right but it's interesting
because if you guys remember the news
there actually was a a a Hamas um he was
like a a son of a leader like a general
within Hamas and he'd be he became a
Christian and he's now like very like
outspoken about the situation in Israel
and trying to like bring context to it
but what's amazing is that his solution
he says the only way you're going to
like change the situation is is by
giving the gospel like this the only
thing that changes you right like his
his rhetoric his mindset was so bent on
hatred like because it's hatred on both
sides like Hamas is like they they want
to wipe out all of Israel like they
don't believe Israel needs to exist at
all and he said he the only thing that
rescued him from that mindset was the
fact that he became a Christian right
now he sees people differently okay so
so I want to hear about this talk about
this drone Warfare just a little bit I
know we kind of started talking about
that but um you you described earlier
like just how it just evil and Insidious
because you're not you're not you're not
even comprehending I think totally TR
truly what you're doing and you guys are
over there um trying to share the gospel
and you have this opportunity you're
talking with these soldiers they're
wanting to drop bombs on these people
that they absolutely hate and I think
you guys came up with a suggestion
brilliant suggestion instead of dropping
bombs has dro the Bible
yeah do we do we understand God's word
to be the solution for the world I
believe so and and not just in a
spiritual sense but in a practical sense
are there are there benefits that come
from God's word I mean you you hear
stories all the time right you know like
just because somebody had a Bible like
on them you know like God protected them
or sent his angel or you know took care
of them so I mean like it is the Bible
the greatest weapon the world has ever
seen well it certainly has caused a lot
of
Wars right yeah I mean maybe and maybe
not caused Wars because at the at the
heart of like what is war it's it's it's
giving into those selfish desires right
you know the desire for more land the
desire for a better political situation
or whatever and then it's unleashing the
basis passions that Humanity has because
in war there's really no rules yeah like
they say there's rules but I'll be
honest there's no rules you know like
when you show up and you have all
Authority and you have guns and the
other person or Community doesn't you
can do with them whatever you want and
that's sadly what's happening right like
in every conflict in every war there's
always been atrocities where the
soldiers have come in done whatever they
want and look look who look who's who
suffers right even like these just Wars
we look back in the day we're like oh my
grandfather fought in the just War World
War II it's like well but was there a
lot of Injustice in World War II oh yeah
on both sides like even America you know
it's like this not Americans are not
innocent here and that's because war is
like the it's the Devil's Playground
right yeah I like that song um we will
study war no more I can't wait for that
moment like there will never ever be a
conflict where we want to take each
other out I remember reading an Ethics
book for school and um you know that
just war concept came up and you know by
the author's definition even though
Revolutionary War he's like wasn't a
just War right he's like United States
was out of line because they were
rebelling yeah and he's like when you're
in Rebellion it's not a just war and I
was like you know it's kind of touchy
subject for Americans right because we
look back on that we're like hey Freedom
this is a good thing yeah so yeah but
going back to what you said about the
Bible I guess I
would I think I know what you mean so
I'm not going to say I'm disagreeing
with you but when you say you know the
Bible causes lot of Wars I think I would
say misinterpretation of the
Bible caused a lot of Wars I agree if if
you really understood what the words or
in the Bible's you know comprising and
getting at is really love your neighbor
as yourself right be self less and and
people have twisted and misinterpreted
and made it sound like something that
they're justified in doing this action
and and I think the most dangerous
person is somebody that thinks they're
following
God and wanting to like kill you I think
that's a dangerous situation scary they
think they do God a service right and
God's all about free will like uh serve
me because you love me not not out of
force and yet that's what a lot of these
wars were like you will worship
according to the way we say or die right
yeah there's no there's no Freedom of
Choice there yeah you know and going
back to your comment about you know
drone Warfare you know how do you get to
a point um it's really interesting you
know Revelation tells us there's a whole
list of people that will not inherit the
kingdom of heaven right and you have
like you know the sorcerers and the hor
mongers and the and the thieves and the
robbers and the Liars you know like all
these people right but in that list
actually says the
cowards will not will not enter into the
kingdom and what's amazing is that if we
could take a picture of all the wars
that have ever been fought especially
coming down to our day and age I I'm
going to make a bold statement here and
this is not in any way to like diminish
you know people who have fought and
served and you know but I'll be honest
Modern Warfare is probably the most
cowardly that it's ever been yeah and
the reason is because we're coming to
the end of all things right so the
devil's Thum print's going to be on all
of it and the devil's a coward like he
doesn't face us front on you know like
on he he's going to hide behind this
he's going to attack from behind he's
going to attack the women and the
children the feeble you know the
feeble-minded and so um this is this is
a picture of actually the conflict that
we see all around us even and it spills
over into reality is that Modern Warfare
is so cowardly you know because think
about just all the high powerered
devices and explosives and guns and
drones and you know you name it that you
can just with the push of a button take
out Untold numbers of people without
even facing you know your enemy yeah you
know what I mean like there's something
there used to be honor you know I mean
like this is kind of the whole setting
of David and Goliath like there was that
there was honor even though like we hate
the Philistines and story still they
were like putting forth their Champion
saying hey if you can overcome our
champion we don't need to have Bloodshed
and like have all these guys wiped out
like let's just go manto man and we'll
settle it that way and whoever whoever's
man wins then boom you know we'll just
go from there and we'll reshape our
policies based on whoever wins and and
it's really actually a pretty honorable
thing you know and so David and Goliath
meeting face to face is something that
we don't ever see anymore like like men
don't grapple with each other often face
to face you know right they're talking
to each other before they're going to
like battle it out right right yeah and
and so it's amazing and today you know I
can push a button you know from a screen
from relative safety or or or a hidden
place and I can just wipe out Untold
numbers of people that don't even see it
coming and man there's a judgment for
that you know like this is not something
that's normal like
Humanity you you can't participate in
these activities and walk away you know
unaffected Ed yeah you know and and
that's that's what we see and and so
like the how do you get to that
point you you get to this point by the
dehumanization of your enemy right and
this is we saw this in Ukraine
especially you know it happens in in you
know Israel and Hamas like everybody
thinks like well yeah if you're
Palestinian you're a terrorist and you
just you just have that mindset you're
not salvageable but even more so in
Ukraine you know we've been there now
for a couple years and on these
Billboards that they have they look like
a a advertisement for some new movie
coming out like some zombie acop
apocalypse you know but it's not it's
actually just an advertisement for join
the third Brigade and what they have is
the Russian on one side and the
Russian's totally this zombie and he's
just like drooling and flesh falling off
his face and like you know just evil
picture and then you've got the normal
looking Ukrainian maybe he's wearing
glasses looks like a geek or it's a
beautiful woman you know very normal
human being so when you look at that
with your mind you're like of course
you're going to vote for the for the
normal looking human being you don't
want the monster to win demon possessed
person or normal person you know it's
like yeah totally playing
psychologically Nazi
propaganda that was just going to go
there yeah they've got a lesson book to
see how that played out and how that
worked and they're using it to its full
extreme and it happens I mean the
Russians I'm sure have their own posters
in Russia you know of the of the other
side you know they they have names for
each other like the ukrainians call the
Russian Orcs you know so
well you know what I mean Lord of the
Rings fans yeah yeah serious like if if
you just killing Orcs you're not killing
people you're killing Orcs right and
that justifi in your mind now I can kill
40 Orcs it's not a big deal right you
know what if the movie poster had like
you know their families with them on
either side of the fence and they're
praying you know or something like that
like like that maybe just would
completely change the context we we we
are reading that book um with our
children for the um um for worship the
the guy that was the German thousand
show yeah thousand sh fall such an
excellent story and it's like you know
I've always even even on this side of
History I've always looked at the German
Nazis and everything is they're like
they're just these Savages yeah didn't
even consider that there was real
Christian people battling on that side
of the fence and trying to do the right
thing yeah you know I mean I've seen
I've seen those uh the soldiers that
were on the Nazi side having to face
Court afterwards and they're like we
were literally just taking orders right
we did what leader to us to do that's
what we're supposed to do by law right
right crazy man well I think that
illustrates too because there's another
there's another really good story too
called the storm on our Shores and it's
about a it's about a Japanese you know
guy that goes to medical school in
California goes to lomalinda so like he
graduates from lominda and then goes
over to Japan to take care of a family
matter and gets sucked into the whole
War Machine you know just just by happen
stance like poor timing right and and so
what does he do like he doesn't want to
he doesn't want fight just want to kill
like he just went through medical school
in the United States like he loves the
United States but yet now he's in it you
know your nationality is causing you to
pick up a side yeah and so he had to go
the whole process you know and it just
goes to and remind you that like there's
somebody on the other side that's
struggling through it just like you are
it's amazing how how degraded Humanity
gets if you if you think about it like
in all these instances it's you you have
to make the other side
less have to yeah otherwise it it
doesn't work but you think about that
from the perspective of
God right God could look at us and be
like they're
less yeah and instead of doing that you
know Philippians chapter 2 tells us how
he comes down lower and lower and lower
and lower to our level and he's like no
I'm going to be with you and I'm going
to live like you I can I could separate
myself you know whether it's like the
Nazis that were like yeah the Jews are
less or like in times of slavery yeah
they they're another race they're less
they're not they're not even human like
Evolution they're less like it's always
less who gets to make that call I think
the antidote is what the Bible's talking
about count people more significant than
yourself the whole Bible is designed to
get you to think of other people how do
I think of that other person I mean
honestly you know the devil's number one
trick I think you can spot him right
away if he's making you feel greater
than and them less than yeah I that's
why I love those those those t-shirts
that is like he's greater than I I think
that's so brilliant if you just had that
perspective with everybody think of
think of it would change Wars yeah not
even not even a religious perspective if
you just took the principal and said I'm
going to consider others greater than
myself MH it would solve a lot that
would you know so you're you're over
there in the Ukraine and um you know I
don't know if you can talk a little bit
about um one of the some of the people
that you were with but you were with a
conscientious objector I think that's
really interesting yeah we we were we
spent some time with a guy that um
decided not to carry a weapon because as
he was looking at the whole situation he
was just like there's just no way I like
the Russians are not my enemy and I
don't want to take life I can I can save
life but I don't want to take life and
man like the devil was working hard to
like take this guy out of the fight cuz
he's there actually like
demonstrating you know the truth how
unusual is that there oh it's it's it's
like not even existent you know like
he's like the only one so cuz there's
cuz there's a lot of like I'll be honest
there's a lot of Christians that they've
made the opposite Choice they've picked
up weapons and say I'm defending my
country my family all these things right
and so they've gone to that extreme
right I'm justified in doing that and
some of the Drone guys that you were
hanging out with that were dropping
bombs on people I mean didn't they make
statements like these guys don't deserve
to to live salvation oh oh yeah like the
whole it it comes from those posters
right they they just when you ask them
well what do you think about the
Russians are they're mindless zombies
like they're all mindless zombies and
you know obviously there are real
situations that they bring up as very
troubling you like one of one of the
commanders that told us he said yeah I
mean these Russians they rape 100y old
women and they you know rape young
children is that something that's
propagated through the media and and the
Machine or is that actually transpiring
no I think it's real I think it's real
you know I think you I think you do see
it because War brings out the basis of
human passion so if if demon demonic
entities are actually influencing men
then what are men going to do demonic
activities right you know and and when
they're released with no restraint
there's no law there's no order you
can't call 911 and say you know to the
police like help me you know like
there's somebody at my door attacking my
family like it's it's Whoever has the
biggest weapon and the biggest biggest
army biggest army and these guys can do
whatever they want you know I think at
higher levels the officers of course are
not going to try to encourage that with
their men but when you're on the ground
and nobody's looking yeah you know this
is this is where this is why a moral
compass is so important and much of war
is also intimidation and fear if you can
get them scared of you you know it's a
it's you have a better chance it's part
of it it's part of it's how do you hold
a population subjection by raping
pillaging and burning their vill I mean
that's that's what you do and they now
know that you are not to be messed with
you know like yeah you put the fear in
them yeah yeah so I mean it's evil like
everything about it is so evil and uh
this particular trip that we were on in
Ukraine we had always prayed like Lord
if you would give us a drone like we we
would drop these Bibles you know like
wherever we could right and God hadn't
given us that opportunity but then
through a series of just miraculous
Encounters in fact helping women on the
side of the road is what led us to this
whole drone team you know it happened to
be her her husband right he's the
commander of this drone
team and um what was so amazing is that
when we sat down with him you know he
was just he just opened up to us and
just started telling us like all of
these horrible horrible things that he's
been through you he was in
maryal and if you remember in Mar upal
uh the the ukrainians were surrounded by
the Russians okay so they were totally
cut off and the forces that were marle
they had a whole bunch of like elite
special forces like Ukrainian Special
Forces and he was like man he's like if
you've ever heard the story of you know
the Spartans and the 300 holding off the
Persians he's like I could tell you
stories of like five Ukrainian guys
holding off hundreds and hundreds of
Russians as they're bombing and trying
to come just crazy like moving material
right you know very few numbers against
overwhelming odds but yet the pain
through all this is he was just sharing
with this you know like he said I had to
make ethical choices between do these
civilian kids live or do my men live oh
wow and his and his men are barely men
themselves they're 18 years old and less
you know what I mean so it's like you
know and he didn't tell us the outcome
like what choice he made but you can
tell like and and he was a part of a 500
unit 500 man unit in which only he his
wife and 16 others survived out of 500
wow I I I spoke to a uh a chaplain one
time and he said the thing that missed
the kid the they I call them kids cuz
they're 18 years old the ones that were
over in Afghanistan and and fighting
over there in in some of the wars that
America was involved in was when you
have a young kid 10 years old 12 years
old running at you and he looks like
he's wearing jackets and you have
literally a minute to make a decision
whether you shoot this kid or not he may
have bomb strapped you and your whole
team's going to go down if you don't
shoot this kid and that that can't help
but to mess you up yeah I mean I I can't
even imagine putting myself in that
position I can't even imagine yeah the
Commander's wife told us these you know
she's a medic she's a combat medic she
literally had kids that were were crying
out to her asking her for help but like
they had mortal wounds and and just she
there was nothing she could do you know
for these kids you know so like that
when you see this kind of evil you know
the commander he said he said I can
promise you God was not in
maral wow you know like that that's how
damaging this whole experience was for
him God was not present marable and and
of course you know we weren't there to
argue you know this or that but but you
can recognize that the devil's design is
to destroy people not just physically
but mentally spiritually emotionally
yeah you know and and that's the tragedy
of
war look at what just observing that
does to the people that are like yep
there's no God yeah that you you have to
understand it
from the largely Christian mindset which
is God is the one who has the most
power so why doesn't God if he has the
most power why isn't he he's the most
responsible and it's interesting that
you kind of started out talking about
war and and rules are you familiar with
the concept of theodicy MH yeah yeah so
in this theological concept The
Odyssey God and Satan are engaged in
this war
call it the cosmic conflict call it
whatever you want and
um the way we understand the character
of God through everything that's going
on is that there are actually Rules of
Engagement yeah that both parties agree
to and it seems kind of like an odd
concept like why would God agree to
anything right right with Satan right
but God is in a very very tough position
right very tough position because
everything he does is being
criticized and the devil's pulling the
like yeah but you're just doing that
because you're God or you're just doing
that because of whatever his accusations
accusing accusing accusing accusing and
so the only thing that God can do at
that point is
demonstrate right is to demonstrate his
love and so you see this play out in a
very real way in like the Book of Job
right so yeah Satan is found in a
Heavenly
Council and God's like what are you what
are you doing he's like you know I've
been walking up and down the
Earth and you know there's there's not a
lot said but there's a lot implied so
when when Satan is making saying like
you know the Earth is mine yeah that's
essentially what he's saying the Earth
is mine right when he's saying that and
so then God's like well have you heard
about my servant job yeah and then
that's when Satan's like oh well yeah
but he just serves you because you give
him stuff yeah and so then God is like
okay you can test him and you see all
that playing out but at the end of the
day God has to prove that he is love
yeah that's a hard thing to do how do
you prove that you're love right when
somebody's constantly saying you're not
love you did this and they're lying
about you MH they're lying about you
yeah how do you prove that you're love
when somebody's always lying about you
well it's it's a demonstration because
you know the scriptures say that Greater
Love have no man than this that he lay
down his life yeah you know for his
friends and and that so that's where the
tables completely turn within
Christianity because if you understand
Christianity and what what God has
demonstrating through the gospel is that
there's actually nobody on this planet
that's not your friend friend well and
if you think about it from from the
Bible's perspective too it says while we
were yet sinners Christ died for us and
and I'm trying to remember if some
translations say enemies or or something
but it's like you know it's like we and
God were not we weren't on the same page
yeah well he's praying father forgive
them who are putting nails in my hands
they're murdering me forgive them Lord
don't let this sin fall upon them and
and earlier you said that that
conscientious objector said you know
these Russians aren't aren't my enemies
the Bible says we battle not against
flesh and blood if we could see that if
we understood that concept like you said
the Bible could change the world if
we're like wow there's this big battle
going on but they're just humans like me
they got a family like me what's causing
this it's this evil influence it's Satan
and these demonic spirits and we're not
batt against flesh and blood if we could
all kind of wake up and see that it
would all end you know and and so that
that is like that's like Mission
objective number one like because you're
stepping into these environments and
working with these soldiers these
individuals that don't understand what's
happening they've been sold on a cheap
narrative right you know that the
Russians are zombies and they need to
kill them all right and so how do you
communicate to them that guys like we
need to we need to zoom out and look at
the 30,000 foot View
and it's only through demonstration so
like as we sat and listen to commanders
he's telling us all these horrible War
Stories and tragedies and you know we
just we pointed into the Bible you know
CU context he's wanting to know like why
is this happening we just went right
straight to scripture we're like look
like this is this is where we're headed
this is what's predicted this this
conflict is not about Ukraine and Russia
as much as we think in the moment that's
what this is like there's bigger forces
at play here because the whole world is
being plunged off the cliff you know and
this is such a small representation
what's happening worldwide so as we
connected the dots for him prophetically
you know from Revelation 13 and other
places in the Bible he just was like yes
he was like this is the problem he
actually pulled out his phone he said
you want to know the real problem behind
this this this uh conflict and we're
like well yeah sure so he pulls the
phone and he Scrolls down there's that
art installation at the Vatican supposed
to I think represent the second coming
of Jesus like super demonic right so he
pulls and the pope sitting in front of
his art inst and he just shows us on his
phone he says this is the real problem
problem he's like this is actually
what's behind all of the conflict that's
happening right now so he's recognizing
that they're demons you know what I mean
it's like wow like like this guy like he
understands more than we we recognize
that that that that that that grab for
political and religious power that is
soon to break upon the whole world is
actually what's motivating much of the
conflict that we see and it's like this
is context this is why the Bible's so
important to give people didn't a handle
on what's Happening didn't the papacy
recently make a state statement that was
condemning Ukraine yeah they've made
yeah several statements yeah and so I
wonder if that plays in a little bit
because he's like well this is the
problem I mean clearly yeah it seems
like the pope is politically taking a
side with Russia and the ukrainians are
like dude what giv you're like giving
them
ammunition because they're fueling both
sides I believe I really believe that
they're all sitting at the same table
and and and they're really on on either
end they know what's going to and here's
throw gasoline on here's the real
tragedy right you know as the commanders
in in marul being surrounded it was it
was the Ukrainian Orthodox priests that
were giving up their positions to the
Russians wow so like they were being
targeted directly by Russian missiles
and bombs and everything because the the
religious estab religious establishment
was giving up their positions why sad oh
because it's it's there's more to it
than just CU their bosses are telling
them yeah you know it's just it's it's
evil right everything's evil about it so
you can see like I don't know if he
fully understood from the context of
like Bible prophecy but that's why we
made that connection as we made that
connection all a sudden he's like whoa
like what else do you know this is not
just a normal meeting here and we're
recognizing whoa this is not just a
normal meeting cuz he's he's not just a
commander he's a commander of a drone
team and so at this moment we're like oh
man like Lord like is this is this it
right is this is this the moment you
know the drones yeah you know and so we
we told them we we said Commander we
said listen we said I know this sounds
crazy but we have a special mission that
we're here for and it's not just for the
ukrainians like I know this sounds crazy
but we're here for the Russians and you
know he's just like oh they're all
zombies they're worthless whatever and
we just I just asked him I said do you
drop propaganda on the Russians and he
was like oh yeah all the time but they
don't read it I was like okay well if
he's willing to drop propaganda then
maybe he'd be willing to drop some
Bibles wow and so then so then we asked
him we said will you drop it took a
while for all this was to Google
Translate right so for him to get the
concept you know at first Google could
totally mess that up you want us to bomb
what so so we gave him and finally he
understood what we were asking and he he
said yes and he and we only this is the
crazy thing we only had nine Russian
audio Bibles that's all we had just nine
so it was like you got to make count
right like this is this is like where it
really
counts and um and so he told us he said
well he he turned him on and turned a
loud as volume setting threw it in the
other room stomped around the room I
like yeah he's like I think you could
probably hear that you know if it
dropped from and landed in the ground
you know and um they're Hardy little
devices so I mean it's not like you're
going to destroy them if you drop them
but wouldn't you be super suspicious of
somebody dropping a little black box
with a bunch of buttons on it I'm just
asking yeah no no seriously this is this
is the this is the sad reality is that
yeah Wars become so deceptive you know
and and we don't trust anything you know
what I mean especially from the enemy
right playing the Bible yeah and they're
like oh yes it's safe you know that'd be
awful but here but here's here but
here's the reality right is that if we
believe God is for us that's right then
he's going to set up the right situation
and the right people and the right cir
where somebody's going to take that leap
of faith and it's going to change their
course and their life forever right you
know so that was what that's that's our
wager our wager and it's not just it's
not just the dropping of the Bibles on
the Russians to reach the Russians I
mean like that you know anybody look at
that be like well that's that's not even
a drop in the bucket like why would you
even waste your time doing that you know
what I mean like mail them to Russia
whatever
but but it's it's really more so for
these ukrainians the Drone teams because
they told they said we killed 20 to 40
Russians every day every day every day
wow they that just their drone unit 20
to 40 Russians they're just
like wow how do you sleep at night and
and that's the that's man these guys are
all family men they're married they got
kids you know and and it's like oh man
you know your heart breaks because you
realize that yeah you're not coming out
of this unscathed you know like you you
may survive the war but but mentally
you're not going to survive no and
that's the devil's design right is that
not only you be his agent but at the end
he tosses you aside and destroys you and
makes you feel guilty that for what you
did look at what you did you ended all
these people's lives now here drink this
bottle yeah exactly you know what I mean
exactly kill you another way so so the
commander you know he said okay he said
give me the Bibles he said we'll drop
them on the
Russians and uh Greg who was with me
there just two of us on this Mission you
know I told we both looked at each other
and told Commander said no we can't give
you the Bibles we said we're coming with
you and he just he was like I don't
think you understand how dangerous this
is and I don't think we understood how
dangerous it was too at the moment right
like in hindsight God's mercy right you
know it's probably a good thing you
didn't realize how dangerous this was
seriously we we actually we sat down
after after this mission was over we sat
down with our conscious objector friend
right and he pulled up his phone he he
said said cuz we told him we were with a
drone team he's like oh he's like you
want to know that the Drone teams are
the most hated teams like in the whole
conflict right he said you you want to
know what happens when the Russian
Special Forces hunts down and gets a
hold of the Drone team and he showed us
pictures they gouge their eyes out and
they torture these guys to death wow
because they're they're wearing VR
headsets right you know so like like
they as a statement they gouge their
eyes out and they torture these guys to
death and this is this is the Fate for
many of these drone teams if they're
caught by the Russian Special Forces
which they're activ hunting them and
they find them like dude it's the worst
kind of death you know and so yeah we he
the commander knows this right we don't
know this the commander knows this you
know so he's like I don't think you
understand what you're asking you know
and we're like no like because because
it's so important you can't just hand
this over to these guys yeah cuz they'll
go in a box somewhere and then they just
keep going it has to be demonstrated
they have to see the power of God right
and so we we said no we're going with
you and he said okay he said you can go
if you have if you have a helmet the
vest and if you have no fear and so it
was it was a real sobering moment like
Lord like where are we at you know like
you know here we go so as a side note
can can I ask you what's going through
your mind at this time are you sitting
there going like okay I have this sin
Lord forgive me for this like Lord I
have this in like clear in the slate no
no it really wasn't like a um I mean yes
you're praying Lord if there's anything
in my life please you know cleanse it
but but really like up to this point
you're seeing how God is leading and
honestly it's it's the next logical step
like this is not a question it has to
happen and you just happen to be a part
of the that story that you know God is
you know using and so it's really more
of just a surrender moment saying Lord
okay whatever happens I'm willing to be
used in whatever capacity like take full
charge cuz you know and looking back on
this we we had talked about bringing our
own drones like we have a DJI drone
we're going to like fly just drop Bibles
where we could you know dud you should
totally name the drones like Bible names
yeah but we thought about it and we
realized the Folly of it right because
we have no idea like where the Russians
are at you know what I mean like it take
us months years to figure out
strategically where these guys are
hiding like we don't know any of this
and and and I think the beauty of it too
is that God just totally swiped us away
from any involvement and said you know
what let me work this out let me give it
to you so that way when you tell the
story like nobody can be like oh yeah
you guys plan this like this was
strategically all put together no no no
this was God like God brought this whole
situation together together connectors
with the right drone team and then here
we are boom you know going into less
than a couple kilometers away from the
Russians so these drones that was kind
of my question is like what size are
these things so these are these are the
$700 throwaway drones I mean still $700
but it's cheaper than you know some of
the other options out there and they're
they're you know yay so big and they've
got they've got a um a trigger release
so they can carry a payload and they can
drop like an 80 mm mortar that's really
what they're dropping mortar or grenade
and and he showed what what what they
actually looks like with with whatever
they put in there the shrapnel and stuff
like this I mean it looks like a little
piece of clay with a bunch of like spiky
things hanging off of the thing and it
just goes in every which direction and
and what I what what was shocking too is
when I saw the video clips um it just
looked these people were like operating
out of a house I mean you could have
been in somebody's backyard you know and
and dropping these things on people it's
crazy yeah it's it's definitely a wild
world you know and and you realize like
most of the ordinances that're dropping
on on humans are not meant to kill and
that's because a wounded soldier is much
more of a hassle to deal with than a
Dead Soldier right if you're killing
them like whatever you know but if
you're wound if they're wounded now you
got to send in guys to rescue them and
retrieve them and it just takes a lot
more resource and then you can bomb the
guys that are coming to get them you
know so it's like it it's evil it's evil
the some intention on evil oh yeah yeah
oh yeah and they told they told us they
told us these stories like that this one
training guy who was who was hit by a
mortar or hit by a drone and um you know
he put on a tourniquet saved his life in
the moment cuz he's bleeding out from
his legs he puts on a tourniquet and
he's literally crawling around on the
battlefield in the mud for seven
days seven days nobody's coming to get
him right because it's too dangerous
nobody's coming to get him he's crawling
the drones are watching him from above
for seven days you can see footage of
the sun I don't encourage you to look it
up at all but you can see horrible
footage where they literally just toying
with people they'll find guys out in the
field and he'll be crawling around
they'll drop a bomb on them and they'll
drop another one they'll drop another
one they have they have they have
footage where they're droing them and
the guy catches it and throws it away
from him because he because he knows
what's coming and then they drop it on
and he throws it away from it's this
whole game of like how long can he
sustain this until one of them finally
gets a different form of torture oh dude
it's it's cat and mouse you know it's so
evil so this guy that's crawling around
eventually he gave up hope and he just
says I'm done and he just undid the
tourniquet and he bled out wow I mean
this this is what you're up against
you're up up against like when you say
hell on Earth this is this is what these
guys are going through like these guys
are literally living through hell in
fact so much so that when we encounter
these guys in the field and we're giving
them Bibles they they they're telling us
God doesn't exist anymore like you
haven't seen what I've seen like he
can't be present like he can't be God
because all this just craziness is
happening but yet that's why the devil's
doing this you know but but think about
it think about it because if you don't
know Christ or you don't have a
relationship with Christ would God
sustain your life for seven days so that
you may come to a point of where you
could actually recognize have that
one-on-one conversation with your
Creator and say Lord I'm in I'm in a
world of hurt I'm in a mess like
whatever you like the thief on the cross
save me yep I I almost think that's best
case scenario as much as it would be
awful to suffer I mean for you to just
have the opportunity to lay there and
just think over the course of your life
you got you got an hour or two or even
days to make a decision like Lord I've
totally messed up I live my life without
you but if there is a God please save me
I mean that thought yeah and if the
curtain could be drawn back I think we
would see just how intense that struggle
between because the devil's desire to
sweep Untold numbers into a christless
eternity and God's trying to save like
the Bible tells us he's not willing that
any should perish but that all should
come to repentance that's it simple like
you want to you want to boil it down to
that this is God's whole game plan he
doesn't want a single person to perish
right but that we just come to a point
of repentance somebody brought something
up that was really interesting just to
kind of explain what spiritual warfare
is really going on behind the scenes
because I'm very fascinated by this as
well that the Demonic realm is really
interested in getting you killed without
being able to make a decision because if
you were to turn your life over to God
and ask for forgiveness guess who gets
transferred all of those
sins right on them and they're going to
suffer in proportion to what they done
that that's only fair that God's going
to do that and and and so if they can
get you to die before you actually give
it back they they're they're they're
freeing up their thing so it's of dire
importance for them as well they're
driven on the hellish demonic Force to
get you to be taken out before you can
even make that decision man now like
what this the Bible says about the wheat
and the tears you know and when they're
questioning Jesus or the the they
questioning you know how did the tears
get here Jesus in the parable says you
know an enemy has done this yeah that's
how it came about yeah and that's the
answer it's hard for people to sometimes
go there or grasp that but it's not God
that's sewing all the seeds of Evil
right it's the enemy right amen right
yeah and and and so the only way you can
really understand this is to have that
Biblical context Tex so that's the fight
right like how do we bring this to these
guys this drone team that we're working
with and so Greg and are there you know
like we're now stuck there with them for
nine hours you know and like they're
setting up all their stuff in the house
and I mean they're using super low
wattage so that you can't trace the
drones they have their own wi-fi system
and they have their own surveillance
drones up in the sky so it's a whole
coordinated like this is super detailed
like they're watching the front lines
they're finding oh oh look there's a
group of four guys over here okay send
the drones in bomb them you know if they
don't succeed here they got another team
that's coming you know it's just the
whole interplay and Greg and I are
praying like you know as we're watching
these screens Lord we don't we don't
want to be party to this kind of
Destruction we don't want to see 20 guys
die in front of us you know like sitting
here right like watching these guys
carry out just this whole thing and so
we just prayed Lord disarm the bombs
disrupt like whatever you got to do like
but like not on our watch right and so
right when we get there the guy's like
hey some of our guys are being attacked
on this front over here they've been
calling for air support so we got to fly
over here and okay sure so you know
we'll get to your project here in a
minute so they load up with the mortar
cach it boom fly it over you can see the
Russians on the screen and they drop it
and they miss and the Russians are now
booking it through the woods you know
and like they're like rearm rearm so
they're flying the Drone back rearm it
another bomb fly it over to get these
guys and they go to pull the trigger and
the trigger mechanism fails and the bomb
is stuck to the Drone oh no they have to
fly the Drone all the way back to our to
where we're at land it in a field
somebody's got to run out disarm the pin
they pull it inside they look at the
trigger trigger Mex look works fine like
there's nothing wrong with it you know I
love it I love it there's probably
Angels up there like just like pulling
one wire and and and then and then it
was amazing because I think they were a
little defeated at this point you know
they're 0 for two you know they were
telling us they killed 20 to 40 guys you
know it's like you know they're a little
embarrassed you know so so they're like
well give us your Bibles you know we're
like yes wow so it was perfect three of
these audio Bibles stacked up fit in the
same size as a 70mm mortar and so they
strapped them on on there tested them
trick release works well and we turned
them all on and synced them like super
loud and we turned them to we turn them
to Advent World radio Cammy utman she's
doing an Evangelistic series and it's
like this isn't just the Bible reading
it can get sermons and everything it's
got the Bible it's got sermons it's got
music it's got all we were trying to
decide like what do we what do we put on
so the first flight that we sent out we
synced it to Cammy utman and it was so
perfect cuz like you know it's like when
the world is falling apart and the end
of the world you know like all these
just like themes they're talking about
you know and the is just like this is
great if it falls from the sky people
are going to be like what is this you
know I so wish I spoke Russian right
yeah you could be there and and so it
was amazing they they attached it they
sent it off and it was so cool because
these guys um you know they knew exactly
where the Russian front was they've been
watching 24/7 blowing these guys up so
they were you know they asked us where
do we want to drop them we said we don't
have no idea like where do you guys
think we should drop oh we these guys
are all Hol Up over here we've been
watching this you know trench over here
so we'll drop some over here they got
some dead Russians here that eventually
they're going to come and collect so
let's drop them close to those bodies so
the same guys that are strategically
knowing where to kill these guys are
like this is the best place to drop the
Bible yeah these guys are these guys are
really sad cuz they lost some of their
friends over here so they need it over
here yeah it's it's wild it's wild the
whole thing is just surreal right you
know and and then and then they're like
oh there's a wood there's a path through
the woods here and and we always see
them come with their supplies and stuff
so let's drop them along the path cuz
they'll definitely be coming along at
some point and then they're like oh and
there's an evacuation Zone and the
evacuation zone is where they pull all
their dead and wounded so definitely
that's a good spot too and we were like
game on like this is yeah this is good
guys we only had one rule for them we
only had one rule for them we said
listen if you drop these Bibles on them
and they pick them up and they're
listening to them you cannot bomb them
oh yeah that would not be cool that is
not cool you got to let them live right
you know and they were like they were
like well haha we'll bomb him tomorrow
you know and it was like it was just
like man you know but but you're working
working with people are these guys
Christians not really you know what I
mean like these are need to to my mind
they're not American right are they
American they're ukra Ukrainian
Ukrainian but you got to realize the
context right I mean Ukraine was was
Soviet block communism most of the
generation our age there have no
connection with God because they were
raised in in the 80s ' 80s 90s you know
so communism was like prevalent so like
they there is no God so in their mind
they don't the only people there that
are of real religious um interest are
yeah Orthodox you know and and but
that's older generation that's like
Grandma Grandpa you know the ones that
the Communist couldn't root out you know
so so but now that it's its own country
they're more secular than anything
because they just don't have the
foundation so you're you're working with
people that they just don't know they
don't know yeah they don't know what
they don't know you know and and and and
you know you brought up a great Point
Mikey about you know Jesus when he says
father forgive them for they know not
what they do it's true it's the same
prayer like dude these guys they just
don't know what they're doing yeah
they've been programmed to hate yeah and
it's and the devil's just sweeping them
into this evil plan and their Pawns in
his hands and you know Lord release
these guys save these guys so it's like
and so throughout the day we had all
these interactions you know in the
beginning the day they wouldn't even
pray with us you know like we were like
hey let's pray for this they're like
whatever you can pray in the corner if
you want that's fine you know but but
then but then they noticed that the day
is different you got to you got to feel
good at least doing something where your
day is primarily taking life just just
the thought of okay we're giving
somebody some glimmer of hope yeah yeah
and it was amazing because because that
they were giving us high fives we were
telling like good job good flight you
know we only had three flights that we
did because we only had nine Bibles so
369 and and yet in between they're
trying to drop bombs and trying to blow
guys up you know what I mean and every
time they're trying to blow people up
like their screen goes blank they lose
connection with the Drone you know like
they miss with their bombs like it was
amazing the whole time that we were
there with them they didn't hit a single
person you know that's God not wanting
them to taint this this stark contrast
of a feeling of what it feels like to
save somebody rather than kill them yeah
yeah they were dropping care packages
you know on on their own lines right
food package the guys that are hiding in
the trenches and we like oh this perfect
like you need to put some Bibles in
there you know and they were like okay
you know like sure you know we can do
that but they're like most those guys
don't believe in God you know and it's
like doesn't matter that's why they need
it right you know so their whole [__]
they even told us this was Monday when
this happened and uh they said it's
interesting said usually on Monday the
Russians are just pummeling us like from
the other side of the river like like
we're get we're hiding in the basement
like we're taking cover like they're
coming real close to hit Direct Hit and
and this Monday like you could hear some
explosions in the distance but dude it
was like we had this little bubble like
and they could feel it they were like
this is different right you know like
God was giving them all those
indications to give them that posit of
you know like this is what's right right
and it was so neat because you could you
were giving them back a piece of their
Humanity because they even s they had
video video confirmation this Russian
after they drop the god pod this Russian
guy who goes over there he picks up the
God pod and it's playing and he just
sits down and he just starts listening
to
it wow I mean that's beautiful I mean I
mean think about it you know if you're a
zombie what interest do you have in a
godp right none yeah nothing right I
mean that's why zom deserve to die
because they don't have a mind you put
the humanity back into the and all of a
sudden they're thinking and they're
looking at the screen they're going this
dude's a dude just like me and he's
listening to what I just gave him like
even though that's not direct
communication it's a form of
communication you know I mean they're
talking you know what I yeah yeah he
just gave him a glow track yeah that's
amazing yeah this is kind of a a side
note but on the whole Zombie thing you
know how that's always portrayed in
video games and movies and all that and
I'm like you think about that
and that's really how God's people are
going to appear to the rest of the world
in the last days I think that's the
problem with zombie movies I actually do
I share the same sentiment because
they're following the lamb wherever he
goes yeah and rest the world is just
like what what do you mean you're not
going to do this and you're not going to
do that and you're not going to do this
you know and and if you look at it the
whole rest of the world is out to kill
God's people right it is no longer I
that live but Jesus that lives in me
you're dead yeah you're you're I mean
for the from from the world's eyes
you're as own yeah yeah you just have
this one way of thinking you you only
have this one Mission you can't deviate
from that you can't do anything else
it's it's it's a strange kind of
parallel if you will and if you get
close enough to someone else and you use
the blood yeah
they wow yeah but I like I like what you
were talking about with these Russ guys
and it reminds me of this this verse in
John 10:10 it says the thief does not
come to except to steal and to kill and
destroy right like what they're living
247 but then they see the reality the
new reality I have come that they may
have life and they have may have it more
abundantly right yeah yeah and it made
such an impact on the commander like
when it came back cuz I think Commander
got a little nervous that we were there
with his drone team you know and he came
and picked us up a little earlier we
were supposed to come back with him but
he like personally came you know in a
truck and it's like you know 3:00 or
4:00 in the afternoon I what time it was
and he was like all right you guys are
still alive droor Bible's good let's go
his whole team is like singing H what's
happening to this place we actually
that's actually that's actually an
awesome no as we were going into the
Battle Zone we actually were singing
because these guys didn't speak a lick
of English so they didn't know anything
that we're saying or singing what you
sing there's power in the blood no we
sang We sang um we sang sound the
battlecry uh we sang the
Lord yeah we did we sang that one sing
I'm in the Lord's army and they love
that one especially because they were
like wow that's such a great to like
what it sounds like military and we told
them we said we said it's a it's a song
we teach to our kids and they're like oh
we love it they're so excited you know I
may never in the Infantry ride in the C
shoot the arer I may fly the enemy but
I'm in the Lord's army yes sir I'm in
the Lord's army yes sir and it just it
changed you got to realize like the
driver he was driving White Knuckles
wide eyes because he knows he's about to
run the gauntlet like like the Russian
kamakazi drones everybody else are
looking at all these little Vehicles
going into the Battle Zone and dude it's
prime target and and he he does this
every day and like like their colleagues
man are blown apart every day and like
you got to run the gauntlet to get to
where you're going and so like it
changed the whole at when we started
singing the whole atmosphere changed the
driver relaxed he like laughing he's
like man okay like these guys are
singing it it can't be that bad you know
what I
mean but that's the power of music right
Godly music and the power of prayer it's
also the power of Hope yeah hope exactly
you exactly this these prayers being
answer though like you guys are praying
like interfere with this you didn't see
anybody get killed right I mean that
that's and that's an answer to prayer
because they kill 20 to 40 people every
day while you're there praying nothing
happens the power of prayer they pull it
they pull something and the pen doesn't
go because there's angels on both sides
good Angels bad angels and like you were
talking about the Rules of Engagement
they can't interact they can't interfere
unless given permission right and and so
they're just waiting like if they just
give us the command we'll go and you're
s the pray Lord don't let this thing
work and they're like all right we're
we're going to clog this Trigger or
whatever and everything's answering
nobody's dying people are picking up God
s and there and even these guys aren't
getting attacked you know you're hearing
it in the distance or whatever it's like
you guys just brought a little piece of
heaven there I so wish you could pray
that prayer like Elijah just just just
open his eyes just for a second and if
like you know every one of those drone
operators could literally look around
the hills and just see like just lines
of angels and and things that are
entered into the war with them I
guarantee you that would completely
shift their mind oh yeah oh yeah well it
made a big impact cuz you know when we
came back and you know we Shar this with
the commander and the the team itself
this was really neat their own creative
processes started to take over and they
they asked us they said well do you
think think we can drop a flag on the
Russians and we were like yeah of course
like that's great it's not a bomb you
know what I mean like drop a flag you
know and and so they they came with this
whole deal they had a spike on the end
big old giant unit flag or whatever
Ukrainian flag and they couldn't do it
when we were there they had because the
winds were too high but later that night
they have this this Flur image you know
like you just see this drone you know
with with this giant flag attached to it
and they're just flying it over to the
Russian side and they just release it
and the flag just goes thunk and it's
like just unfurled waving In The Wind in
the ground oh yeah ight and the and the
Russians the Russians were livid livid
you know what I mean and they couldn't
send anybody out to take the flag down
because there's drones over head right
so what did they resort to they took
their own kamakazi drones they just
start flying it to try to hit this flag
but they're missing they can't hit it
and for like 24 plus hours this flag is
just standing there and they're trying
to bomb it and they can't bomb it they
can't take it out wow and uh and we told
our it was the same pilot that flew some
of our Bibles we said we said hey we
said you're you're saving life and he's
like what do you mean well think about
it like just by dropping a flag like the
Russians are wasting all their drones on
this flag which in the end what does
that matter you know I mean and he the
light bulb had gone off right and we
just told him he said so the solution
could be more simple than we think you
need to drop more Flags you need to drop
more Bibles yeah you know and it's just
like it's just those subtle little ways
that that you know God is is is working
and it's like how amazing would it be if
God could capture the the hearts of an
entire Ukrainian drone team and these
guys are so motivated and fired by what
they see the miracles of god that they
they decide to stop
dropping bombs it was interesting the
mortars they cost uh
$40 I think 50 they're about 50 bucks
for the mortar right wow how much does
the godp Pod cost godp pod's about $40
they're almost equivalent but we had
three of them sacked together for the
mortar so we're way outnumbering the
value of one mortar right you know like
we're we're $120 to their $50 right you
know and it's like and it is like it's
it's a much more viable weapon that if
they can just see the value it it could
game over it could throw a wrench in the
devil's whole scheme you might be
dropping one God pod but how many people
are listen to that like gather around
guys yeah dude exactly and like you said
war so deceptive I mean they had like
inflatable tanks and all kind of stuff
war is all about deception that could
have easily been a bomb but this dude
heart racing picks That Thing Up and
puts it to his head that's amazing man
and then and then and then just just
imagine that conversation that he had
when he went back to his buddies like
dude you got to hear this like you know
what I mean and they're all sitting
around and like you know wondering where
did this come from clearly the
ukrainians would not drop this thing on
us and they're probably sitting there
going dude angels are out there you know
and like who knows what kind of
conversations they would began to have
right right and and the Ukrainian
Commander he was so impressed with the
mission what had happened he we asked
him we said we'd like to give you more
Russian Bibles and he actually said okay
he said give me 200 wow taking ERS it
was just it was just they went from went
from 9 to 200 you know what I mean like
and this was so neat is that in in the
whole con we had we had almost neglected
to tell him that we had Ukrainian Bibles
so he really only thought we had Russian
Bibles right oh wow but but yet he's
willing to the Bible says feed your
enemy and this Commander un unknowingly
is feeding his enemy before his own
needs and it's like whoa like how
amazing is that you know and then we
told him said hey we got ukrainians too
you drop these on your own men as well
how do you think that's going to work
are they going to be like okay today we
only do Bibles or is it going to be like
okay one will'll kill people one we'll
do a Bible I mean that's that's where
that's where prayer is so important like
even now like dude pray for these guys
pray for this Commander this drone team
like we've been messaging keeping in
touch with them and he told us he said
uh you know we're about 25% through what
you've given us already so they're
working on it like they're a quarter the
way through and and so that means
they're dropping bombs as well as Bibles
you know what I mean but but somehow in
in that crazy mix like you know it's
just like all these other Amazing
Stories like how does God get through
the fog of somebody and when they're in
a state of addiction or the state of
rebellion or whatever it's like it's
just that one little step and all of a
sudden mhm the door starts to open and
the mind starts to consider the
alternative you know and God can work
with that you know like we take one tiny
little step and he's running to meet us
right and that's our prayers for this
drone team is like they're GNA be
they're going to be God's drone team
dropping Bibles everywhere that's
amazing can you tell me how this even
started all this story just started like
I'm with this drone team but how did
there got to be some miracle Story how
how does a normal person your Scotty's
brother how do you end up like I let me
Ukraine Army drone team before he
answers this it it is so fascinating to
me when you when you listen to these
guys because here is a Ministry that is
very practical in its terms of like we
we we theorize all day long like how to
share the gospel right I mean we yes
we're we're we're pushing buttons and
we're putting things out into the world
but we're also putting things out into
the world sitting at a desk right I mean
yes we go out and we speak in churches
and stuff like this but but but how this
stuff actually works in a situation that
is a hostile situation it is amazing to
just listen to no plan no no don't know
what to do but somebody gave me all
these God pods and I'm going to go
deliver them and then it's just like
boom God goes nope here meet this person
go here get in a car here well this this
is why you know and I've said this
before you know on the show but I'll say
it again this this is why movies are so
damaging because what we've discovered
in our ministry is one of the greatest
action adventure films that I've ever
been a part of very true dude I would
watch a movie about what you're talking
about I want that to be a movie I've
ridden tanks I've ridden helicopters
I've we've dropped stuff from drones I
mean it's it's like when you talk about
like James Bond it doesn't even compare
to like what or MacGyver doesn't even
compare to what God how many Blackhawk
helicopters have you flown on in your
ministry in your ministry operations
it's been quite a number of them but and
Chin you can't just roll up to a
Blackhawk helicopter pilot and say
Excuse me sir can you take me and my
friends like it's not going to happen
Happ but this also illustrates in
showcases that the message that we have
for this time from the Bible is that
important yeah like God would bend
even modern militaries to his command if
it was just for reaching somebody with a
message of Hope for this time and that's
the power so so we don't we don't the
the sad thing is we don't recognize the
power that that is actually available to
us or the gift that's available to us
and and that's why it's like man God
does not want to see our youth go down a
path that the devil is going to suck
them out of the fight he it's like now
is the time to join the Lord's army now
is the time to see God do amazing things
for you and to build a narrative and a
story and and and and pull you into as
the main character for like I mean you
think of all these Bible stories of the
hero greats that have been before us
like dude those are all movie worthy
subjects in which are incredible when
you think about but yet God's wanted to
do even greater things today because
time is so short like we're run out of
so the um I guess I kind of look at it
like we the Drone Pilots or the ones
pressing buttons right from afar to drop
the pit load where to go and the reason
I say that is
because I remember um when I went to
Switzerland a couple years ago the guy
that invited us I was asked he was
telling me his testimony it was you know
quite a long car ride to get to where we
needed to go and he said he's like I
know God controls the YouTube algorithm
yeah he does and he had he had been he
prayed a prayer and then he was watching
some videos and I I don't remember if he
fell asleep or something somehow later
like he kept no I know what it was now
there kept being the same video
recommended no matter what video he
watched the same video would come up in
his recommendation on the side and had
nothing to do with what he was watching
yeah and he noticed because he works in
it and he's like that's really strange
and so he watches that
video
and he had I think he heard a voice that
said after watching the video he like go
get your Bible now keep in mind he's
like living very
secular not quite atheist but probably
agnostic kind of like lifestyle right
and he's like sitting there going like I
don't even have a Bible wow and the
voice tells him it's under your bed in
this location oh wow that's crazy and he
goes and he finds the Bible that he had
since he was like 14 years old wow and
he's able to start reading it and of
course God's just taking them us on this
journey he's like I know God controls
the YouTube algorithm yes there there
was a comment that came into one of our
videos that that somebody had mentioned
never heard of our ministry didn't even
consider some of the things that that we
would say and literally a video in the
recommendation pop up and it and and she
said it was like a very like Stark like
you need to watch this video from this
ministry right now and it was like
questions that she was beginning to have
on the media like in her mind she's
having questions and and she felt like
an angel literally pop that up onto the
YouTube channel and went here's your
answer right here watch this one that's
when me and Scotty are just like this is
serious work like Angels like our
mission is to create the content whether
it's you know another Ministry putting
print books Bibles whatever we have to
make something physical for the angels
to point people to and they're like okay
these people they made a video they put
it up this person's dealing with it
watch that video now well and and that's
why that's why you know it it's a team
right like we all there's no part that's
that's insignificant right and God's
desire is that we're all you know a part
of that team and laboring for Souls
because the at the end of the day the
only currency that matters in this world
is Souls that's was being traded one
lost on a daily basis and so how do we
how do we enter into that that that
perspective to know that it's not about
it's not about your career it's not
about your five you know your your 401k
in your bank account it's it's it's
literally about how many Souls you know
can you bring with you to the kingdom
and and until until we get to that point
man there's a lot of people out there
that just don't know so how do they not
you just like the Bible says they won't
know unless somebody preaches to them
you know they won't know unless somebody
goes and tells them you know so it's
like this is why the preaching of the
word whether it be through media whether
it be going in person like it it takes
all of those aspects you got to have the
delivery man that delivers it think of
the one guy that came up with the idea
let's load the Bible up on this little
thing that's can be easily translated
into all kinds of different languages
and you're just uploading this thing and
it's a little plastic device he had to
go to China and figure out who's going
to make this thing think of the effort
that went to that thing for the the the
device to be handed to him to go over
there and to save a soul if you could
just follow that whole trajectory of how
that thing played out it'd be pretty
crazy yeah it's amazing Brock how do
people get a hold of you if they want to
get involved with Gideon rescue and to
jump on board and have a crazy
experience if you at home are sitting
around on a computer and you don't do
anything um for the gospel and you want
to ride around in Blackhawk helicopters
how are you going to even initiate this
conversation Brock how are they going to
get a hold of you well we have a super
secret underground base that's uh
difficult to locate so it's it's hard to
get a hold of us but you do have an
email just kidding we we do yeah we do
have an email but you have a direct line
to
Heaven um no you can um you can get on
our website there's a a way to contact
us you know I we find this a lot that a
lot of people have interest in what
we're doing we get a lot of people that
are like we love it we want to be a part
of it this would sound really cool my my
son needs this you know my daughter
needs this
whatever but it's really those that are
truly persistent at the end of the day
you know onus is not on us it's on you
know the receiver to say hey this is a
calling that I feel God has really
called me to and I want to be a part of
this they're just following the
promptings of of how God's leading them
so if you're serious about it yeah get
in touch with us we'll have a
conversation we know we'll pray with you
um the Harvest is great the labors are
few we desperately need hands like
that's the biggest need we have you know
so and let me tell you um just working
in this you know you might not be able
to go on a trip you might not be able to
to actually dedicate amounts of time but
I'll tell you what every single person
works right so you should be actively
involved in God's work if you're not I
hope and pray that you will consider
funding some things like this I mean it
takes money energy effort and all of
those components together are equally
important to be able to make this this
this Cog wheel go forward and uh at the
end of the day um I think you will look
back on this experience and say what
what did I do for the kingdom of God how
did I enter into this work at this hour
and I think that's what you're going to
look back on in eternity and uh if
somebody says I'm only here because I
got a god pod dropped on me in the
middle of a
war I mean you're not going to hear any
you can't pay for that kind of of of
beauty so I hope and pray the least you
can do is pray for this ministry amen
and so just uh if we have enough people
really praying that their doors can be
opened and that they can run forward
with boldness that's entering into God's
work as well we thank you for listening
to this conversation Gideon
rescue.org org you can check them out
we'll put a link in the description
below thank you for liking our video
please share and subscribe seriously
even a simple way that you can enter
into God's work and help this video get
out there in the algorithm is to just
like our video or subscribe to it if
every single person that literally
watched our videos that said you know I
I I I don't I I can't do anything for
your ministry you can push that little
button right there and that helps other
people see this content so we thank you
guys for tuning in and we will see you
next week
[Music]
I'm sorry do we know each other it seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you really wish
I had a conversation
[Music]
starter oh hey what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
created you oh
Jacob and he form you oh
Israel I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go out no
more I will on of
[Applause]
God shall strength
feel
shall alone but by every word I that
proceeds from the mouth of
[Music]
God o